o ombro só
coca cola com bebel e hogan
[Música]
ai meu deus que ajude o lado disse love
quem falou da difícil muito bem vindos
mas um bilhão e mulher e os traduz numa
óptica que vai ser um daqueles vídeos
contra 500 primeiros juntos só um vídeo
ou seja neste vídeo vou ter cinco
primeiros lugares e eu vou ter um
experimento com coca cola do experimento
com uma falta eu vou fazer muitos testes
e que no segundo set porque muita coisa
não sei se vai continuar uma delas é
tentar injetar gás dele dentro da coca
cola e ver o que acontece na que o
quanto bebia coca-cola eu vou ficar com
uma voz fina e não sei se lá que se o
sugar gás deu e tocar flauta o som da
flauta também vai ficar mais fino que se
eu colocar o exclusivo dentro da filha
do gasto extra que esse maluco é assim
mas eu acho difícil eu não sei acho o
castelo é inflamável eu não sei mas não
estou com pressa bola quem surfar bem e
vamos sentar em cima com gás deus será
que dá pra dar mais toque a chutar e não
só isso estou continuando a solicitar
essa bola vai para muito longe com ela
consegue voar eu não saio tudo isso vai
ser disponível que neste vídeo com este
cincos primeiros e alcançar a lei só
vestiu muito lhe que neste dia é muito
necessário proibido compartilhar este
vídeo com todas as outras pessoas que
estão acabando e tem fim e só deixei
muito marca que instruiu estão foram
inscritos nos cleveland e outra coisa
muito importante só a sério mesmo tipo
de ataque tudo que um estúdio pessoal eu
quero muito apoiar dois pilotos de
corrida que eu adoro portanto quase
ninguém embaixo e eu preciso da vossa
ajuda para eles ganharem comida portanto
entre o aluno sai deixa o diretor até lá
acho que vocês vão encontrar um botão
onde disputará com o facebook lá você
então bota o facebook claro que só não
sabe tudo confiável portanto vocês tão à
vontade não vou apanhar aqui os filhos
sabem não ela vai por ser um dos pilotos
quando vocês podem estar e eu quero
muito que vocês votem no di grassi e no
bruno batista vamos lutar muito muito
muito nestes dois pilotos porque o quer
muito que eu caí e pois você escolher
estes dois pilotos só clicar no botão e
lobos que já está em curso a memória
deste grande portanto é muito obrigada a
quem ficou embora
os primeiros nem louco é o nosso é o
primeiro experimento que nós vamos fazer
aqui é tentar testar o gás dele o ouvido
em mulheres
vamos deixar aqui copcal atuado por que
eu vou testar isso porque nós combinamos
o caso dela a voz fica mais fina estampa
de guerreiro funciona já toda a gente
sabe
então se eu tentar inalar gás dentro
pelo nariz acho que vai dar o mesmo
resultado é esse vamos ver meu seu e de
maior ajuda morreu junto pra lá vão
enfiar o estudo em escala muito grande
olha só essa bola como é que fica no
bandeirinha mas vamos lá 32 bull lá ô ô
ô se um pouco com 32 o atendimento
pessoal sério investimento é muito bom
fazer mas eu vou tentar de novo agora 3
de junho vai rolar lá funciona funciona
e nós álcool e o meu ouvido tampado e
agora vamos estar dentro do filho e
imagina eu eu amo injetar gás de uma
vida eu vou te ouvir comgás delma
assunto não consumir estugarda elas rio
não quero eu estou comendo a bola faltou
nos mover não foi bom falou a londres
não acontece nada e eu consegui ouvir
isso estão resultou em nada é porque
está aqui só afeta as cordas vocais é
muito estúpido que eu fiz mas tem muita
graça porque se continuar é sempre bom
nos experimentar
coisas que nunca fizemos é por isso que
existe não é pra vocês verem com as
primeiras coisas que vocês não fazem
porque é estúpido eu sou o único absurdo
muito feliz na única eu acho só se
deixarem muito mais que eu vou tentar
enfiar gás de muitos buracos limpeza
muito mais que você já sabe o que o
estudo é desculpa e fica mais fino não
achei muito legal
agora vou ter que limpar isso não é que
fiquem pelo nariz
olá pessoal segundo experimento que eu
vou fazer aqui com o caso dela é vamos
ver se eu consigo enxergar esta bola e
vamos ver se ela vou eu sou campeão de
espanha é muito um fórum muito leve
a voz é porque são muito bons que
encheram gosto pouco gastel mas eram
aquelas roupas normais podem ficar mais
leves mas não vou estar aqui para dizer
que vou porque o material é muito boa de
fora é muito fino não sei se vai voltar
mas é sempre muito está ok eu vou tá ok
funciona está enxergando e agora está na
hora de darmos o nosso amigo ela 321 vai
ser boa não está muito mais para a
solução só se fosse uma boa normalmente
não faltar mas eu tenho certeza
falei isso para nós é muito muito leve e
isso é fácil
[Música]
foi o meu deus
ray do cansaço cantar mas segurou o
castelo como vocês puderam ver o caso
dele sinto não esta bola mais leve mas
não suficientemente para ela voa até
porque a quantidade de gás dela que tem
aqui dentro nós suficiente para levantar
esse peso é perceba fosse maior com isso
o material eu acho que ela vá acho que
sim eu vou guardar com esta bola porque
sei que vou utilizar mais vezes aqui no
canal então vou deixar aqui e ir para lá
atual próximo experimento vamos ver
divulgado pelo altera os tons que isso é
uma falta de professores da ufal que se
as pessoas têm tempo você vai alterar a
voz eu acho que também vai entrar falou
do alto é normal estar só vocês a coisa
que não havia falta vamos lá ver caixa e
faça uma boa partida e ajudar aqui pode
apertar e apertar aqui sou normal
gazeta ru e comeu expressa uma pizza em
vez da falta o ok eu vou tentar tocar a
bola com a mão num ano como podem ver o
caso dela e sim torná falta mais segura
e agora vou tentar fazer isso como o
próprio volta normal
gardel
vai ter precificado e até mesmo pessoal
está bem que eu tenho aqui uma canção
olha só o que é isso ao futebol
brasileiro e funciona aqui na nossa
falta e agora vamos para o experimento
que eu tenho mais curiosidade e acho
esses dois primeiros que em sou muito
curiosa é porque na verdade não sei o
que é que vai dar então vamos testar o
quarto prémio vai ser a experimentar
coca cola com castelo dentro vamos ver
se isso realmente afetar nossa voz ou
não eu não sei porque eu nunca antigas
dentro do mix assunto fica lá acho que é
porque qualquer coisa tem de observar em
tempo e 16 lugar dentro fica lá não sei
como está vai achar melhor
[Música]
ai meu deus está tudo em cima e nós
temos aqui nossa coca cola e claro que
já fiz bosta aqui na merda claro que sim
sempre tem que gostar eu vou te provar
um pouco
não há nada melhor que isto é muito bom
muito mal agora próximo a ser muito
simples porque a espanha enfim a
história dos anos 40 amostras
vamos lá então tentar colocar castelo
dentro da nossa coca cola faz um só
coração eu acho que é profundamente
irregular 321 bons saiu muito o curso
quem fica o cachorro é isso o que eu vou
colocar mais feminina
o machucado da coca cola no sul
o homem muito gás véu e uma coca cola
querem saber em 32 sul
olá como a china não ficou isto futuro
mas tem muito mais baixa do que a coca
cola com canela e não funcionou
acho ok vamos entrar com outra maneira
eu vou tentar sugar gás dele e do bina
coca cola que forma vamos lá tentar
negociar com a latinha nós mudamos pra
quem tem olhos castanhos e eu voltei
vamos tentar de outra maneira diferente
aí nós não só de modo muito esse ipca
caiu muito tempo vamos fazer aqui uma
maneira de fazer isso eu vou colocar o
castelo dentro da coca cola e enquanto
estiveram derrotar o gaúcho eu vou
colocar aqui o canudo e sugar a coca
cola e ver o que acontece é porque assim
vai direto mesmo vamos lá
está muito gostoso como 32 kun
bom eu digo pra ontem estava escuro
maneira tão perto de ir embora 31 vai
pegar fogo
vai ver é o pior local é jogar com muita
calma muita calma e fica sempre libertar
o gajo isso mesmo
vejo o lado pessoal tá funcionário o meu
deus negócio e como é muito mais fina e
até mesmo no 3 piso vai isso isso
olá pessoal aqui quem fala é o olhar que
seja muito bem
olá pessoal daqui quem fala a verdade
seja muito bem vindo é mais um vídeo não
fica mais fina e com muito gás dentro
estava aqui dentro acho que ainda tem
nada aqui que tudo fazendo uso da coca
cola está aqui dentro diz que nunca e
ver se conseguimos falar com ela e
também para 3 no bairro e olha só contar
aqui eles têm qualquer coloque para lá
então pessoal para o quinto e
experimento é porque sou como é que o
estado não como um ser mágico cola cola
com ela eu nunca mais ou então se vocês
comentarem mais coisas pra fazer eu vou
experimentar nós vamos lá então próprio
experimento que é tentar explodir esta
bíblia de coca cola assunto cachiello
inflamável justiça
vamos lá fora então porque está sempre
gozou não posso perder isso aqui já
sabem só nunca tentei está em casa e eu
vou testar vamos ver o que acontece mas
nunca experimentei em casa vamos lá fora
o pessoal sabe que nossa bíblia do caso
dela e vai ficar e que assim o bahia
agora é só para que os nossos três
explosivos podem só já aviso que este
gene a lei está aí agora é só coar e
acendendo vai dar muita bola olha só
assim o advogado dela não é inflamável
mas vamos ver o que acontece pelo menos
abrir um buraco que devia também
incluído nela tipo não sei se vai abrir
nem sempre o mundo está assim acho que
sim tá ok e agora é só aprender é bom
pessoal como é que vai ser plantação eu
vou acender que exclusivo girma
praticadas e um dente vai ficar aqui
filmar muito perto maior com
exclusividade e pode até pegar fogo
inclusive mas eu gosto né e 2 para 3 21
vai aumentar nos últimos dias houve duas
explosões e olha só ficou todo 18 para a
fita adesiva
ficou tudo de funk vamos saber como é
que ficou na minha casa e disse que cuba
em seus cada ano eu acho que entrou
ligeiramente para dentro foi mas eu acho
que eu fiz muito isso pesa muito o
sistema então é pessoal nós arriscamos
aqui um pouquinho não resultou em nada
mas pelo menos experimentados e agora
vou ter que marcar época todos seja
vamos lá pra dentro agora e só espero
que tenham gostado de ver este vídeo
vejam só como ficou a bancada olha aí tá
tudo com a câmera tira ninguém que nos
quiseram ver mais vídeos destes cinco
muito sofrimento dentro do próprio vídeo
cometem em baixo que é que vocês querem
ver bis quiserem vir mais coisas com gás
dela também comentem porque eu acho que
eu acho que eu posso fazer umas coisas
27 com nosso amigo é só foi inscrito no
canal inscreva se deixem muito mais que
também eles fiquem até à próxima fase
[Música]